this session doesn't have as strong a
theme as the first session so
what i'm i'd like to do actually is uh
let people let speakers take questions
during their
during their uh slot because we'll put a
little more of an emphasis on that
rather than on collecting
for the end so feel free to uh interrupt
them
i will monitor the uh
chat session and so the speaker doesn't
have to but you can also just
unmute and uh you know i think we should
try and make this as friendly as
possible
um so in terms of the times every
speakers you know gets eight minutes but
i'll do this like soccer injury time
right
if you foul the speaker with a really
hard question that i'll give him a
little more room
and um we will of course stick around at
the end of the session for any q a or
discussions so
anybody who wants to we can we can do
that at the end all right
so um we can now move to our
first speaker who is alan liu's
uh about distributed load balancing work
with sarah madian
uh alan are you queued up
all right do i just share my screen you
just share
um to the there's a share screen option
at the bottom of your zoom window
and then and then you pick the
presentation yeah there you go can you
all see that
yeah we can see it all right go ahead uh
uh hi i'm alan i'm from mit and today
i'll be talking about
distributed load balancing a new
framework and improved guarantees
so uh yeah let's begin with the problem
setup
so in the problem that we consider we
have a set of sources s
and a set of workers w and they are
connected in a bipartite graph
so in the graph shown the sources are s1
s2 s3
and the workers are w1 w2 and w3
and now each source has one unit of load
and the goal in our problem will be to
distribute
the load on each source among its
neighboring workers so for each source
we can split its
load among its neighboring workers
however we want
and now once we have distributed all of
the load we can compute the total load
on each worker
as the sum of the loads over all the
incoming edges so for instance in the
allocation
shown in the diagram the total loads
would be
one-half two and one-half respectively
so now what is the objective in our
problem so the objective is we want to
balance the total loads on the workers
as much as possible
and the way we capture this balance in
this objective is we have a convex
objective function
fee of l1 l2 up to lw
and now uh so we actually do require a
few
things about feed being symmetric and
well behaved but almost
all natural objective functions do fall
under our framework for instance
we might want to minimize the maximum
load on any of the workers
or we we might consider an l2 objective
where we want to minimize the sum of the
squared loads
we might also consider a more general lp
objective
now finally our goal is to develop a
distributed algorithm
that computes a nearly optimal
allocation
so uh so we work in the standard
distributed model of the congest model
where in
each round the uh each node is allowed
to send a logarithmic number of bits of
information
to each of its neighbors
so this problem is motivated by
applications and web servers and search
engines
so we might think of the sources in our
problem as corresponding to the query
sources so for instance
user is querying a web page and then the
workers in our problem correspond to the
data centers
that are like serving the requests and
since there may be millions of
users and millions of uh workers we want
a
distributed algorithm that converges in
a small number of rounds
so one of the key innovations in our
work is
that we are able to deal with a general
convex objective function
and not just say the maximum load
objective or a linear objective function
and as we shall see that these are
actually quite different and it requires
several new ideas to go from say linear
objectives to general context objectives
so let me say a little bit about related
work so the first line of related work
is in something called diffusion type
load balancing
so uh diffusion type load balancing is
a slightly different model but very
closely related
where the workers may communicate
directly with each other
and split tasks amongst themselves
however algorithms in the diffusion
load balancing model also like naturally
translate to algorithms in our model
but the main caveat here is that
algorithms for
diffusion type load balancing require a
polynomial number of rounds
to converge where polynomial means like
polynomial in the size of the graph or
other graph parameters
there's another line of related work and
distributed matching algorithms
so sort of these matching problems
correspond to when the objective
function in our problem is linear
so these are like say maximum matching
kinds of problems
and so for these types of problems there
are actually algorithms that
converge in a polylogarithmic number of
rounds however
as i mentioned these the problem of
matching is fundamentally different
because it is a linear objective as
opposed to a convex one and
uh one way to like see the intuition for
this is
that when you have a linear objective
the optimum always occurs at a vertex of
the feasibility polytope
however when you have a convex objective
the optimum may occur in the interior of
the polytope
so the problem is like quite
fundamentally different
so maybe as you might guess our results
are
that we have a an algorithm for load
balancing that computes a nearly optimal
solution
and a poly logarithmic number of rounds
so to compute a one plus epsilon
approximation we need
log n log squared d over epsilon cube
rounds where n is the number of nodes
and d is the maximum degree
and so when the objective is
to minimize the maximum load we have an
improved algorithm
that converges in log n log d over
epsilon squared rounds and this is
uh faster than a direct application of a
parallel mixed positive lp solver
so uh let's briefly try to understand
why previous load balancing
algorithms get stuck with this like
polynomial dependence on
these graph parameters so the previous
load balancing algorithm so for like say
diffusion type load balancing
they all follow the following paradigm
which is that when you have
two workers whose loads are in balance
you try to like linearly shift load from
the higher loaded one to the lower
loaded one
where more formally what i mean is like
consider in the following diagram we're
looking at
source s2 and then the loads on two
workers l1 and l2
so if l1 is bigger than l2 then what we
want to do is we want to shift like
delta times the difference
load from f a to h b where the parameter
delta is the step size
and the reason why we have this
polynomial dependence on the
graph on these graph parameters is that
if
you shift the load too aggressively so
if delta is much larger than one over
the maximum degree
then what can actually happen is that
your algorithm will like oscillate and
you can't actually prove conversions
so you actually need to set delta to be
quite small and this
means that your algorithm actually needs
a polynomial number of rounds to
converge
so what we do is we actually adopt a
completely different approach in our
paper
so the first insight is that if we know
the target load so if we know in the
optimal solution what the target loads
are supposed to be
then actually computing the like
satisfying allocation is a matching
problem
and as we said mashing can be solved in
a poly logarithmic number of rounds
so now this leads to the following
natural algorithm for minimizing the
maximum load and
all right so the algorithm will be we
maintain target capacities for all of
the workers
and we initialized the targets to be
very large so our initial
state is feasible now each time step we
test feasibility with the given target
capacities and then if it's feasible we
decrease the target capacities
until we reach a configuration that's
barely feasible
so this approach actually works for the
maximum load objective function
however dealing with general context
objectives requires a much more refined
approach because we can't decrease all
of the target capacity simultaneously
so as sometime a bit short on time i'll
go through this
very quickly but basically the
we use uh so we use this matching
algorithm
of this previous matching algorithm by
agrawal at all
in a very non-black box manner and what
we do is
we each time we test feasibility we find
some set of workers
that we call tight and
the by analyzing this matching algorithm
in a very non-black box manner what we
can show is actually
that there's a certificate for these
tight workers that actually in any
feasible
allocation we cannot improve on these
set of tight workers so then we can only
decrease the target capacities for
workers that are not
tight so essentially what happens is
that to prove optimality we actually
have a hierarchy of certificates
showing that at the end of each round
our solution is nearly optimal among all
of the workers that we've frozen so far
so yeah uh so to quickly summarize
everything
we give a distributed algorithm for load
balancing that converges in a poly
logarithmic number of rounds which is
a significant improvement over previous
algorithms and really the main insight
is we go beyond these linear traffic
shifting algorithms
and instead we like iteratively test
feasibility and then
update our target capacities and
that's all for the talk so yeah thanks
for listening
it's a little bit like one hand clapping
in the forest or something um
questions we have a little bit of time
while the next speaker sets up
yes there's my bus car
just if you have a question speak up
yeah hi
uh uh i have the query on on regarding
the comparison with the classical
uh um graph stage uh have you performed
any
uh uh uh empirical uh uh
uh evaluations and how does that compare
to that
uh yeah so we do not have any empirical
evaluations
done yet but yeah
thanks anyone else
no other questions we're ready for our
next uh talk
uh work by nom solomon and shai solomon
both from tel aviv
university on a generalized matching
reconfiguration algorithm
thank you i hope uh i'll give you a two
minute warning i didn't do it in the
last talk i'm sorry but
um i'll i'll raise my hand or something
at a two minute warning
okay so can you hear me
yes okay great
so i'm going to talk about the maximum
matching problem
and i'm going to use the abbreviations
mcm and mwm for maximum cardinality and
maximum weight matching
respectively and as you all know
this is a well-studied problem we
consider it from
the following reconfiguration
perspective
so imagine that you have some
approximately optimal matching m
let's say 1.1 approximate mcm for some
graph g and let's imagine that
this matching is being used for some
practical purpose
in particular the blue edges are the
edges of m and they are giving service
for some application now we suddenly get
access to a better matching game prime
a bigger matching let's say and
obviously we would like to
transform from m to m prime in order to
give a better
service so the black edges are the edges
of n prime
instantaneously we would like to move
from m to m prime but it's not always
possible you can imagine some practical
constraints and
we are going to consider a gradual
transformation process
well
there is a possibility to change just
one
matching edge per step okay so you can
imagine that there is a sequence of
matchings that we
are outputting starting from m and
finishing at
m prime and every pair of consecutive
matching should be very similar almost
identical to each other
up to a single edge change and we also
require that all those matchings are
of large enough size okay so
specifically we
we do not want to go down in size by
more than one unit
with respect to what we started from or
what we finish it
but this is not always possible so if
you think about it for a moment you see
that sometimes we
really need to go down in size by two
units
so the only question here is this one
unit
of decay versus two units and this uh
problem was studied first by ito ital
and this is a decision problem
uh of whether there exists a gradual
transformation process
or not and they gave
a fairly non-trivial polynomial time
algorithm for this
that's based on some known decomposition
and they also conjectured that
a similar result can be achieved for the
weighted case
and they also studied some more
configure reconfiguration problems
okay so this is a decision problem there
is a polynomial time algorithm for it
and more broadly there is a pretty
large value of work dedicated to
reconfiguration problems
and the part of it is motivated by
applications such as
motion planning computational biology
and many other
applications and it's also uh intimately
connected
to combinatorial puzzles and games
if you think of a configuration as a set
of elements
so for example a matching is a set of
edges
then in a typical previous paper
the requirement was that any pair of
adjacent
configurations is
very almost identical the symmetric
difference size is precisely one
this is very restrictive sometimes there
are
other restrictions but the name of the
game here is to pose
a restriction aiming to model some real
life
situation scenario and
get a decision problem and try to solve
it what we
are proposing is to actually relax the
problem and
we are using this additional parameter
delta
which controls the symmetric different
size
so instead of one it could be arbitrary
and we notice that when delta is
3 already then there is a simple
linear time gradual transformation
process and
so this is the theorem i'm not going to
read it but
we can go from any matching to any other
matching m prime
sorry from m to n prime using at most
three changes
to the output matching at every step
and we never go down in size by more
than one unit
and as you can see the running time of
this transformation process is linear
in the size of the matchings and this is
also
optimal it can be shown that this is the
best we can opt for
and it's also easy to prove it's
more challenging to generalize this uh
for weighted
matchings here we are allowed to go down
in weight
by w units w is the maximum edge rate
and by the way we can refine this
parameter w but
not for this short talk and
and we also observe that if delta can
grow to one over epsilon then
we can make sure that the weight of the
output matching
throughout the entire process never goes
down by more than this factor
one minus epsilon factor and in general
we get this
the maximum of these two terms we never
output a matching
that has weights smaller than
the maximum of these two terms and this
also can be shown to be optimal
now the takeaway message the main
takeaway message of this work is not
these
transformation process theorems but
rather
their applicability to the area of
dynamic
matching algorithms which is uh
pretty active this last few years and
in the most basic setting we have a
single
change to the graph pair step usually
it's an edge update but it could also be
a vertex update
and the most basic quality measure is
the update time we would like to get a
small update time and
by now there are many
algorithms with pretty small update time
also in the worst case measure
and they also can achieve pretty good
approximation guarantee and i'm not
saying that this is a fully
resolved area of research not at all but
i just want to say that this measure of
update time is pretty well understood in
contrast to
uh it's let's say cousin the recourse
bound which measures the number of
changes to the output matching
uh and it could be much bigger but it
caused one much it could be much bigger
than the update time
and this parameter is not
nearly as well understood and in fact
surprisingly perhaps almost every
dynamic matching algorithm has a very
high
uh worst case recourse bound
besides one or two exceptions and even
some of them call
a high amortized recourse bond
some of the known algorithms and we are
going to employ the
the theorems that i mentioned a few
moments ago
in order to get uh
this result so i'm going to very quickly
go over this theorem what we are saying
is this you have
as a black box any dynamic algorithm
that can maintain
any let's say beta approximate mcm
with an update time t for nt
then you can transform this algorithm a
into
a different algorithm a prime that
maintains
a possibly very different matching
but with roughly the same approximation
guarantee beta times one plus epsilon
and the update time of this resulting
algorithm this transform
algorithm is very similar to what we
started from up to this
additive term
and we can achieve a worst-case course
bound of roughly one over epsilon
so that's um what we get roughly and
if you care about an approximation
factor of one plus
epsilon roughly then you cannot do
better than this if you would like to
improve the the recurse bound
asymptotically below one over epsilon
assuming one electron is
super constant you cannot do so even in
the incremental and decremental settings
and even
in the amortized sense and finally we
generalize this for weighted graphs
and so this is like the last
few seconds if the edge weights
are between 1 and w not necessarily
integers
then you can see where the w pops up
the update time grows by an additive
term of w over epsilon
instead of 1 over epsilon and the worst
case for correspond
becomes w over epsilon
and yeah that's it thank you
okay thank you we're about a minute and
a half overtime
so if there's only a very rapid question
and maybe the next speaker can already
share screen
what's the next speaker is it paul
yeah i'm here mike okay so thanks a lot
thanks a lot shai
i guess we'll move on to the next talk
remember there's time for discussion
also at the end
and also a reminder to the speaker i'll
kind of raise my hand with that little
yellow hand two minutes
uh when you have two minutes left okay
so thanks shy and the next talk is
uh paul anders pop and roger
wattenhoffer on
defaults in financial networks which is
exciting stuff
yeah so you can see my screen right
yes okay uh thanks then
hi everyone i'm androshpop and i'm
presenting a joint work with roger
watenhofer
so the talk is about financial networks
uh which is a very timely topic because
nowadays the financial system is like a
very
interconnected network of banks and
financial institutions that are
are connected by these debt contracts
and other financial derivatives
so if one of the banks goes bankrupt
then it means it can't pay its
liabilities and then other banks will
also go bankrupt
and so on you can have these ripple
effects throughout the whole network
so it's very important to study this
whole area in a
in this network based perspective and
the base model to study these networks
uh has it's actually very simple it has
notes for
banks uh you have these uh each bank has
a specific amount of money which you see
in these little rectangles
and it has that contract saying that for
example
you has to pay one unit of money to v
based on this you can already define
assets and liabilities for each of the
banks
for example bank you gets one unit of
money from this source node
uh it has three units of money itself so
it has a sets of four and on the other
hand it has a total liability of one
towards b
or if you look at this bank we uh then
it has a sets of two because it gets one
year
one unit of money from you and it has
one unit of money itself
but on the other hand it has total
liabilities of four so this is the
interesting case when
v is bankrupt or in more financial terms
uh it's in default because it cannot pay
all of its liabilities
and the model assumes that in this case
what we does
is that it takes all the money it has
and pays as much of the liabilities as
it can
proportionally to the payment
obligations it has
and also what's an important parameter
in this model is the so-called recovery
rate of v
which is simply the portion of payment
obligations that we can fulfill so in
the current case it's two over four
or one half so this model can already
capture a lot of phenomenon in these
networks but recently
it's also been extended by another kind
of contract to make it more expressive
and this is a so-called cds or credit
default swap which is a
very popular financial derivative in
practice
so essentially a cds is a conditional
debt contract where you and we agree
that if a specific uh third bank goes
into default
then and only then you has to pay two
units of money to be
for example or it can be any other
amount too
uh or more specifically
the payment obligation on the cts in
practice is the weight of the cds
times one minus the recovery rate of
this reference bank
so for example if the reference bank can
pay all of its liabilities it's not in
default
then there's no payment obligation if it
cannot pay at all
then the payment obligation is the whole
weight of the cds
and if it's somewhere in between then we
get something in between
zero and the total weight so this is the
financial network model that we're
studying
and what's kind of new in our work is
that all the previous works have studied
this from a static perspective
in the sense that they analyze the
network in sense of finding
equilibrium points payment
configurations that fulfill these rules
and
whether there's there exists such an
equilibrium whether it can be found in
polynomial time stuff like that
what we do instead is we look at this
whole setting more like a
as a dynamic process step-by-step
evolution of the network
where each discrete time step is a
so-called update
essentially the banks have an officially
announced recovery rate
which might or might not equal their
current balance and we
follow this process as banks update
their recovery rate to
their real situation so for example if w
has an
initial recovery rate of one uh maybe it
later learns that it's only going to
receive two units of money on its
incoming contract
but at this point this is not really
known to the network maybe this is
information that's not available to
other nodes so
w has to explicitly announce make an
update and announce that it only has a
recovery of one half
and it is only at this point that the
payment obligation on the corresponding
cds will change
so just to look into some examples as to
how this works
if you've seen the long version of the
video you might recall that this is
this is a running example we have two
banks u and v which both start with a
recovery rate of one
which means that uh none of them get any
assets currently from the source node so
they can both go bankrupt and if u is
the first node to report a new recovery
rate of zero
then this means that we get new assets
so we will not go bankrupt
and on the other hand if v is the first
node to report a new recovery rate of
zero
then you get new assets and uh doesn't
have to make an update either
so based on who does the first update uh
we end up
in two very different outcomes of the
system and actually you can also see
that there's a
there's also a third equilibrium which
is not even uh
obtainable in this call sequential case
and another interesting example is
is this graph for this financial network
where initially there is no payment
obligation on the cds because
v is fine initially which means that
first you will go into default
and then we will go into default and
then this
creates a new payment obligation and the
payment on the cds
so now we sorry you comes back from the
default and has to make an update back
to one
it's it can pay its liabilities now and
then
v does the same which then creates again
a payment obligation of zero on the cds
so this gets back to the
original state of the system and what
we'll see
is a periodic repetition of these few
steps forever
and the whole system will not stabilize
at all
so these are the basic properties of
these financial systems
uh that are kind of important to know so
nodes can occasionally come back from
the default not equity
every equilibrium is reachable in this
whole sequential process
process might go on infinitely never
stabilizing and
it's also heavily dependent on the order
of updates
sorry two minute warning okay
uh so the uh what we
uh look into in detail is the
uh is the different properties of
so details of these different properties
uh for example uh
stabilization time wise it's not only
possible that it's infinite it's also
possible uh
that the system lasts for a very long
time if it's eventually
stabilizing so an exponential number of
steps maybe
and to do this you can essentially build
gadgets that behave as a
as a binary counter that counts from all
zeros to all ones
which is kind of interesting because it
also shows that these financial networks
can act as a model of computation too
or in terms of ordering of updates you
can you can
uh study how the uh how hard it is to
find the ordering at least
gives the least amount of defaults in
the final state and it's very ordering
dependent
uh because you can have a system where
if this node defaults first then there's
one default in the end
if this node defaults first then almost
everybody is in default
and in general this is an mpr question
you can do this by a simple reduction to
max sut
by having variable and close gadgets
it's actually quite straightforward
or you can look at it from the
perspective of a single node
uh finding the best ordering for a
single node our first example already
shows that in
some cases it's good to delay your
default because that's the only way you
can survive
but there's also more interesting
examples where surprisingly the best way
to
to act is to default as early as
possible and then this will
create a chain effect in the system
which brings you back from the default
in the final state and uh
all together this is also something
that's an mp heart problem
you can essentially count uh conver
combine the binary counter construction
with the maxed construction
uh to show this and kind of
show that the binary counter counting is
enumerating through all the variable
assignments
and then a note can default and stop
this counter
and then it receives a proportional set
to the number of satisfied clauses so
the note selecting
the best time to stop the counting is
essentially the same as finding the best
assignment
so besides these it's also an
interesting better question whether this
model is realistic and in this sense the
worst
property is this stabilization uh
and it's a natural question to ask
whether we can change this
and i'm of course not going to go into
detail with this now but the
key point here is that by changing two
minor things you can actually come up
with a monotone sequential model
where the recovery rates of every node
can only decrease
uh and then stabilization is guaranteed
but of course this also means that
default is not reversible once it
happens so we've lost another property
from the system that we kind of liked
the short question thank you for the
attention
great thanks very much quick question
while the next speaker sets up
because we're again a little over
um in which way does it depend on the
cds being present in the system what if
you don't have cds
yeah so it's a good question so in
terms of this uh uh this
long stabilization that that's uh that's
a place where this really comes out
so even without the cds you can have uh
have a version where the even with
simple debt contracts
where the uh system is only slowly
converging to an equilibrium and then it
will still take infinitely many steps
so essentially i didn't talk about this
but this first point here this
optimistic updates is a kind of a way
for smart updating to
to kind of remove the steps of the
process which are only about
uh information propagation and this
iterative solving the fixed point
problem uh and only keeping the steps
which actually change the liabilities
so so depending on how you define the
model
uh it's either also
a long stabilization time with only
depth or we're not
okay well thanks thanks again very much
very interesting and we should
switch to our next speaker if you could
share a screen
uh the next talk is the variable
processor cup game
by alec westover and william cusmall
and hi okay can people hear me
yes we can hear you and i'll give you a
two minute warning again okay thanks
so uh i'm william kuzmal this is joint
work with alec westover
and al questor was actually a high
school student when we were doing this
work
and this talk is on the variable
processor cup game
so let me start off by just telling you
about what's known as the pea processor
cup game
this is a game that takes place on n
cups each cup is capable of holding
an arbitrarily large amount of water so
here the water
is shown in grey and there's two players
there's a filler and an emptier in each
step of the game
what happens is the filler distributes p
new units of water into the cups
so here p is a parameter and here the
new water is shown in light blue
and the only constraint on the filler is
that they can place at most one unit of
water into any particular cup
on any particular step now once the
filler's done that
the emptier gets to select p different
cups
and remove up to one unit of water from
each of those cups
and so here p equals three in this
example
now the emptier's goal is to minimize
what's known as the backlog of the
system
so that's just the amount of water in
the fullest cup
and you can think of this as being a
scheduling problem so the cups represent
tasks
the water in the cups represent work
that needs to be completed on those
tasks
and the emptier represents a p processor
computer
that gets to select p tasks at each time
step to make progress
on that's how to think about this
classic p
processor cup game
now of course the most natural emptying
algorithm for this game is the greedy
algorithm just always empty from the p
fullest cups
and after a long line of research what
we now know is that the greedy emptying
algorithm
actually does pretty well so it achieves
backlog
big o of log n where n is the number of
cups
and it does that no matter what the
value of the parameter p is
moreover it turns out that this is
actually the optimal the asymptotically
optimal algorithm
so no deterministic emptying algorithm
can do better
than a bound of log n
in addition to studying the greedy
emptying algorithm there's been a whole
bunch of different
a whole bunch of research on on on the p
processor cup game over the last 50 or
so years
and so here's just a sampling to give
you a sense
and one of the things that i think is
interesting about all of these
different directions of research is that
implicitly they all share one common
assumption
which is that the parameter p that is
the number of processors in the game
is fixed
so in this paper what we wanted to do is
we wanted to ask the question well what
happens if you let p
change over time so we introduced what
we call the variable processor cup game
and it works exactly like the standard p
processor cup game
except now the parameter p is a function
of the time
t besides that the two games are exactly
the same
and i want i want to point out there's
really no fundamental reason why p
should fluctuate in the same way for the
filler
as it does for the emptier over time but
by assuming that it does that
we make it so that it's a fair fight so
both the filler
and the emptier have the same amount of
resources as each other
in each step and again you can think of
this
as a scheduling problem the only
difference is that now
the application that we're scheduling is
on a shared machine
a machine that's shared with lots of
other applications and so the number of
processors available to our application
can fluctuate over time that's how to
think about the variable processor cup
game
now when we began this work um
i should say that we really thought this
was just going to be a simple exercise
because because of course for each
individual value of p
the p processor cup game behaves the
same the optimal backlog is just
log n and so we thought surely if you
let p
fluctuate over time this shouldn't
really change anything
and so yeah the key difference here is p
changes over time
and so what really blew us away with
this in this paper is just how wrong our
intuition was
it turns out if you analyze the greedy
emptying algorithm
the best bound that you can prove for it
now is big o of n
so previously our backlog was log n now
our backlog shoots all the way up to
order n
and it turns out that's not the greedy
emptying algorithm's fault
because it turns out that actually for
any deterministic emptying algorithm
there's a filling strategy that achieves
a backlog of omega of n
within two to the n steps so the greedy
emptying algorithm
is still optimal it's just that the
optimal backlog
is so much larger than it was before
of course this prompts a whole bunch of
interesting questions so for example
what happens if we consider shorter
games games that aren't exponentially
long
maybe then the backlog drops
dramatically
and again we were kind of surprised
because what we found
is that the uh even if you consider
games that are quasi-polynomial length
so length 2 to the poly log n
the backlog still stays quite large in
fact you can force a backlog
of n to the one minus epsilon for any
positive constant epsilon of your choice
and this by the way prompts an
interesting open question which is
what exactly is the right backlog for
these shorter games is it order n
or is it order n to the one minus
epsilon and i think that's a fascinating
question to explore
so that was shorter games and still the
backlogs stayed large so next we asked
okay well what happens if you consider
a randomized emptying algorithm maybe
then
the backlog shrinks
and one thing that you should know about
when you when the emptier is randomized
is that you assume the filler is what's
known as an oblivious adversary
that means that the filler doesn't get
to see what the emptier does at each
step the filler is blind
and what we proved is that if the empty
is a randomized emptying algorithm
and if you assume that the emptyer
satisfies a certain common property
and by common i mean it's a property
that's satisfied by all the known
algorithms and past work
and this property is called being
greedy-like if the emptiers are
randomized greedy-like algorithm
then remarkably there's still a filling
strategy that forces a backlog of n to
the one minus epsilon
and this filling strategy is an
oblivious filling strategy
and of course again this prompts a very
natural open question which is
can you prove a similar result when you
don't have this constraint on the empty
ear
sorry can you prove a similar result
when you don't have this constraint on
the emptier
and in particular what if you just
consider an arbitrary randomized emptier
i think that's a fascinating question
and i don't know the answer
so those are the results in the paper
and when you put them together you start
to get kind of
a fascinating story which is that the
variable processor cup game
despite aesthetically being very similar
to the classical pea processor cup game
these two games really are very
different than one another
and i think this prompts a whole bunch
of possible directions for future work
generally kind of what happens if we try
to consider various forms of beyond
worst case analysis
so for example you could consider
resource augmentation that is
what happens if you let the emptier
empty slightly more in each step
than the filler is allowed to put in you
can also consider
smoothed analysis so what happens if you
either randomly perturb what happens the
behavior of the players in each step or
you randomly perturb
the starting state of the game and you
can also
consider placing restrictions in the
filler so i think this is particularly
promising because
you could for example restrict the rate
at which p changes over time
and it turns out that if you look at our
constructions in the paper p
changes really rapidly it changes in
kind of a fractal-like pattern
and so i think placing restrictions on a
filler is a really interesting direction
of future work
and i think what these directions of
future work will really help us
understand
is just what are the ways in which these
two games different
and is there any way that you can modify
the variable processor cup game
to get a game where the backlog again
returns to order login
thank you very much
thanks um thanks for also finishing
almost with the a lot of time so
um my quick question would be okay
give us some feeling for why the results
are so different in the pe case
in the variable p case yeah so i think
the intuition is this
the intuition is that you you have a
recursive construction
basically by induction so you say i i
know how to do a construction n minus
one cups how do i do it on end cuts
and what you do is first you use your
recursive construction to fill one cup
way up
and then for the rest of your
construction you increment p by one and
you use one processor worth of resources
to just
hammer on that cup and make sure it
doesn't get emptied out of it doesn't
fall below its current height
and then again you use your recursive
construction to fill a second cup to
that height
now once you've got two cups at that
height you can just
do a little bit more work to put this
this is a tower of hanoi explanation for
the two to the end
that's right and so really what ends up
being really fascinating is trying to
get this kind of recursive construction
to work um
i mean the basic construction is pretty
straightforward in some ways and then
getting it to work for shorter games
and against randomized uh adversaries
ends up really kind of being where you
start to get um
kind of more you you need slightly more
unintuitive ideas to pull that off
okay does anybody else have a quick
question before we uh we should
start on the next talk
okay if not thanks again and remember
again there'll be time for conversation
later
and the next talk is a new model for ant
trail formation
and its convergence properties
this is shivam garg
[Music]
and shivam is presenting yeah can you
can you hear me
yes okay hi everyone i'm shivam and
as told this is joint work with
moses deborah and kiran
moses kieran and myself are computer
scientists whereas
deborah is a biologist who is also an
expert in ants
okay so this work started
from trying to understand some of the
field observations
by deborah and some of her colleagues
in particular some observation about
turtle ants so these are ants
that nests and forages and trees so you
can see some of them
in this picture
so let me tell you a little bit about
these ants first so in particular we
will talk about turtle and cephalotes
goniodontis okay so these ants form
trail networks
that are constrained to lie on a natural
graph formed by
tangled branches and wines these trail
networks
connect several nests and food sources
and often extend hundreds of meters
spanning many trees
and how do these ants traverse these
graphs so these ants lay pheromone as
they move along and this pheromone
guides their choice of edges to traverse
so here is a picture of tangle branches
in which
these ants forage
now coming to the surprising observation
about these ants
so chandrasekhar at all in 2019
they use data from field observations
to understand what objective function
these
trails might be optimizing for and
perhaps surprisingly they observed that
these ants form trails that
approximately minimize the number of
moves
and they argued that that since there is
a small probability of
exploration by these ants at each node
minimizing the number of nodes reduces
opportunities for these ads to get lost
now the computational question here is
how do ants find such paths without any
central control and
with minimal computational resources
so so we come up with a model to
understand this question
so i'll first describe the model at a
high level
so our model has bi-directional flow of
ants in a directed graph
so there is forward flow that proceeds
along forward edges of this
directed graph from source to the sink
the source can be thought of as a nest
and the sink is like a food source
and the backward flow goes in the
opposite direction
these ants lay hormonal edges as they
traverse them
and this pheromone level
decays victim and finally some fraction
of this flow gets lost as it passes
through each node this is crucial
and this mod this way we are modeling
the loss of fans
due to exploration so
now let me describe the model in a bit
more detail
so for every edge uv in this graph there
is a pheromone level associated with it
and the pheromone level at time t plus 1
is given by the pheromone level at time
t
plus the forward flow at that edge at
time t plus the
backward flow multiplied by a d k term
delta
so this is how the pheromone gets
updated now how does the flow get
separated
so let me first talk about the forward
flow so each
h in our graph has a forward flow
associated with it
and the total forward flow at a vertex
is defined as the sum of the forward
flow
along its incoming edges multiplied by
1 minus a leakage term associated with
that vertex so this leakage
accounts for the loss of fans due to
exposition
and now how does this flow gets updated
so the flow the forward flow at
any vertex divides itself among the
outgoing
edges based on the pheromone level at
these edges
and there can be many rules for this
division may be the simplest search rule
is the linear decision rule
which divides the flow proportional to
the
pheromone level at these edges we also
consider some other rules but i will not
talk about them
here so this was for the forward flow
uh the rules for backward flow are
exactly the same
just that the flow goes in the opposite
direction uh
i'll not go into its details so this is
the whole model uh
okay so now let me describe our results
so our first result is for the case
when the incoming forward and backward
flows
do not change with time so we show that
for graph consisting of
two parallel paths let's say p1 and p2
from s2d
where p1 is the path with minimum
leakage if the incoming
forward and backward flows do not change
with time
and the initial pheromone level at all
edges on p1 is positive
then the flow dynamics converge
to the path p1 so
eventually all the flow will go through
the path with minimum leakage
here leakage of a path is defined as the
fraction of flow that would leak out
while moving through this path so this
case of
parallel paths is somewhat restricted
so to understand what happens for more
general graphs
we ran some simulations these
simulations were for
general graphs drawn from various random
graph families
and in all of these simulations the
dynamics converged to the path with
minimum leakage
and our conjecture is that this result
holds for general graphs
actually even in the seemingly simple
case of
two parallel paths the proof requires
coming up with a careful construction of
a potential function
so even though the model is simple to
describe
analyzing its dynamics does become
non-trivial even for
seemingly simple cases
so let me show you a simulation that
illustrates this result so here you can
uh see a graph with
source and destination the forward flow
coming out of the source vertex and the
backward flow coming out
out of the destination vertex and each
node is denoted by a dot and this dots
have different sizes so the larger the
size of a dot is the smaller the leakage
there
and eventually we would want that the
flow goes through
the path with larger dots so
or the path with minimum leakage so
let's see what happens
so as you can see slowly the flow is
converging
to the path with larger dots or minimum
leakage
okay
so so when all the vertices have equal
leakage here
note that the path with minimum leakage
is same as the path with minimum number
of nodes
so this gives a possible explanation for
how ants might be finding
paths with minimum number of nodes or
minimum leakage
and this was for the case when the
incoming backward and forward flows
do not change with time what happens
when these flow do change with time
so our next result is for that case
i'll not go into the details of that
result but
there we essentially show convergence
the shortest path earlier
the convergence was to the path with
minimum leakage
here we are saying it converges to the
shortest path when the flow is
increasing
with time and there is no leakage
there have been past works that have
shown that argentine ants are capable of
finding the shortest path in us
in certain simple graphs and from past
works we also know that detection of new
food sources can positively reinforce
the
rate of flow of fans this result is
basically saying there might be possible
connection between these two phenomena
and it would be really fascinating to
explore experimentally whether certain
ant species actually
change their flow rates to find short
paths
we also have some other interesting
results that i'll not
uh cover here
maybe now i'll conclude with the
takeaways so we give a model for andrea
formation that
provides a possible explanation for fuel
observations makes some interesting
predictions
it essentially demonstrates how new
algorithmic insights often emerge by
investigating the unique constraints
faced by nature
the purpose of this work was to
introduce this model
and make a first attempt at trying to
understand some of its properties
and there is still a lot left to be
understood here
maybe the most pressing open problem
here is
to generalize our convergence result to
general graphs
i think i'll end here thank you thanks
very much
a quick question
any um that was a question to the
audience any quick questions
good well uh thanks to all the speakers
of the session and we'll stick around
after this
um i just want to tell everyone
it's now by mike watch 10 26
so the other session should be i think
starting within four minutes
so if you're planning to move over to
session a i think now is the time
and if you'd like to stick around here
and chat with the
speakers from this session i believe
they're they're all going to stick
around and we'll see if
if there's any interesting conversation
um
okay so again thanks to all the speakers
of the session
any questions ideas improvements on the
results
um well i have an informal question in
fact
speak up okay so itcs seems to be
captivating a special philosophy whereas
it endorses new directions in
theoretical computer science
so i've just been wondering why the
authors
selected itcs particularly to submit
their works
okay if any of the authors want to
i think maybe i can speak i think
as you explain the philosophy
seems like to
the philosophy of itcs encourages new
models
and works so that was
one of the reason and another perhaps
somewhat unknown reason
is that idcs allows you to
finally publish just an apps extended
abstract
so that you can also submit your paper
to other journals so it's helpful if
you're working
on interdisciplinary stuff with other
people who wants to somewhere
at other places stock and fox doesn't
allow that so
that is also helpful
do you think your research would be
supported by
conferences other than itcs or not
uh when you say supported by what do you
mean exactly endorsed and uh
endorsed or accepted at least
i think the question is uh do we think
that the
essentially the program committee did
the program committee here have a
different objective function
than a stock fox soda program committee
is maybe that's more your
question okay okay
that i think if i'm interpreting your
question because i'm not sure that the
author is in the position to answer that
i will say that on the program committee
it was definitely
um
you know as we sort of formulated you
know we discussed a little bit what
we're looking for it's not radically
different from any other
of the theory conferences but i think it
is there was somewhat different there
was definitely
attention to the more uh
uh speaking of ants the more exploratory
part of
of what we do in the field
yeah and so from the perspective of the
cup games work
um the thing the reason we decided to
submit to itcs is because
the thing that we found really exciting
about our work was
all the possible directions of future
work that seemed to pop up from it
and so it's also a little unusual in
that usually when you're doing work on
cup games you're proving very positive
results
results that say oh if you're in a real
world system you're you have nothing to
worry about
this is just going to go great but this
is almost the opposite this is kind of
the first really in some sense and i
mean this in the most positive sense but
it was the first really negative result
that we've seen for cup games and so
that's why we were
that's why we're excited to have it you
can see us is a venue for that paper
and do you think there is a much greater
potential in itcs
well the cup game papers have been
getting consistently into soda and stock
in the last few years and so i think i
think people i think it's an area of
research that people are excited about
uh but i think atcs was i mean i don't
i i don't know but i i think
the thing that i like about all the
talks i've seen is just all the like you
just think wow like think about all the
different ways i could go with this if i
wanted to work on this problem
speaking of which if i could slightly
shift a thing a question to ponder
um on the financial networks thing so
it's a very
um i'm very curious about the model it's
very interesting to have a nice model a
computational model for these credit
default swaps
now one thing there that's obvious and
you sort of addressed it a little bit in
your talk is
i mean this is a very fragile thing
right you know sequences of
you know very long sequences or infinite
sequences it's very fragile and the
the kind of uh faith and you have to
have very strong faith in the model to
extrapolate from the current financial
networks i think to this computational
model
um just wondering if you have anything
to bri
you know i i'd like to feel i'd like to
hope that we would have something useful
to say about
financial networks and the more a little
closer to where they're really operating
i i wonder if you have any insights on
that
well it's uh that's a good question so
we've been
looking at this topic for uh a year or
maybe two now
and we kind of feel that so your
question is good in the sense that we
uh we haven't really found uh the right
model where we feel that okay this
this is uh gonna be something that gives
us insights in practice
or or where we can really get take away
messages
for uh for the for a real world
financial network so kind of
uh to maybe to summarize it briefly so
there's only this
so there's this base model where you
only have depths and we
often kind of felt uh that uh that's
too simple to really grasp what's
happening in in real world and then we
started working on this model with cds's
and um and we've actually looked at it
from a game theory perspective from a
complexity perspective now from the
dynamic process perspective
and we've kind of felt that this is the
uh
this is the other extreme in the sense
that it's too expressive it practically
allows you to do
everything which is also unrealistic so
actually we're kind
of aiming for what you're saying finding
something in between that
allows you to take away messages for
practice
uh but that's bit still up for the
future i guess if i could i could just
issue a follow-up so now instead of let
me ask about the other extreme so
okay so you just answered me the
question about somewhere interpolating
in between cds's and
a two simple model with just that um
going in the other direction
is is this model as expressive as you
can get from sort of all financial
derivatives
um or is it is still somewhat limited
so uh i think it kind of captures the
main phenomena in the sense that uh
that now some banks are happy that other
banks are
doing good and it can also express the
fact that like short positions some
banks are
are sad that like happy if some other
banks are doing worse
uh but generally so of course there's a
lot of things
for example timing is a crucial crucial
thing from practice which is still very
much missing from this model that uh
some if you do a like short
or something in practice then it usually
happens concrete time when you have to
know the value of something
so it can model specific phenomena
uh it's all it's especially in the game
theory fashion
sense we felt that it's kind of doing a
lot but
we're still missing a very very uh large
number of aspects from practice in the
sense if you
if you really want to understand what's
out there
okay thanks anybody
anybody else i had a question for shivam
so you talked about um
generalizing your results to other
graphs but
maybe the real question is like you know
do the graphs that show up in
the real world have any special
structure that makes it
the problem easier um
do you know if there's any evidence of
that or have you talked to your
colleagues about
such an approach uh
so i think the the graphs that appear in
real world do
have some kind of special structure
maybe they are sparse so the degree of
each node is
small for example but i think
they are reasonably complicated in the
sense that
i think my my guess would be if we can
get to a proof for that
uh that will be enough to get the proof
for general cases
so in that sense
i think the missing inside i would be
really surprised if there is a missing
inside that
only applies to let's say sparse crafts
but
not everything systems okay thank you
anybody else yeah uh hi uh
i had a uh follow-up query
with respect to
[Music]
gradients so is it
completely deterministic um
so i mean for the
ant trail uh formulation you have to
have
a complete idea of the environment and
uh since uh those uh
back propagation
[Music]
has to be done for optimizing the
non leakage patterns
so i was just thinking uh uh
did you also consider the um
depth first uh approach with respect to
the calculation of the
or is it the simple gradient
formulation with respect to the back
propagation
um i'm not sure i understand
the question uh so so there is no back
propagation ingredients in our case so
there is so you can just think of it
like ants going from
food food to the nest and nest to the
food source so there's two wave
and so one is we are calling let's
nest to food source we are calling it
the forward flow and
other the backward flow there are
no gradients or back propagation in
that
[Music]
okay so from uh source to sync and then
from
uh sync to source then if the simple
uh kind of uh uh those optimized parts
are
just being widened to have
that much data being uh propagated
through this green parts as you
add yeah thanks
other questions
so sorry i started to stick with the ant
thing but you what's the data
this linear for the choice model for the
flow
this linear thing is there's some it's
just like that
the simplest natural thing to do or
there's
uh okay so so we have some results
that basically say that
essentially any non-linear rule
will not guarantee you convergence to
such paths so
once you shift to nonlinear rules
the guaranteed convergence property will
go away
but at the same time it doesn't say that
these things will not help
the non-linear rules so maybe it will
not find the minimum leakage path but
it can still nudge these dynamics
towards
parts with less leakage so
linear is sort of a nice spot where
you can get provable convergence
and sort of some intuition for why
things might work for
other cases maybe just another thought
um is the linear model you know you can
think of this as a stochastic thing
after all these ants are
fairly stochastic uh in which case this
would resemble the
the polio earned model right so um
yeah so yeah yeah so so basically uh
there is the
[Music]
this uh
thing called reinforced random walks uh
which is
i think polio's own model is also just
one of one example of that so in
reinforced random walks
uh you have an agent doing a random walk
in a graph
a weighted graph and the weight of the
edge gets incremented
every time the agent
visits that edge so our model is
somewhat related to that but
there is there are some crucial
differences
in the sense that there are many ants in
our model whereas there is
a single agent there is leakage in our
model this decay of
yeah but it is yeah it is closely
related to reinforced random works which
have been studied
anybody else
great well thanks everyone for sticking
around and maybe we can uh
or we can switch over to session a or
get a coffee or whatever you want to do
so
thanks thanks all for attending the
session thanks again to the speakers